Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
they dropped a brand new Sonic Three Trailer
when they released it.
There was also a bunch of news
about returning characters from the previous movies.
Villains,
totally new characters from the lore in the games.
So we'll break it all down.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Super Bowl trailers in the next week
is going to be crazy.
Like Deadpool
three trailer is going to break the Internet.
Very timely because Shadow's the main character
in this next big movie.
There were a bunch of people
that actually just released their own Shadow fan film,
which is really, really good.
generally,
the Sonic movies have done a good job of breaking
the curse of video game movies,
like they'd actually been pretty solid.
Most of the fandom is actually pretty happy
with what they've been delivering.
so very optimistic
that Sonic three will also continue in that trend
but the new teaser trailer starts with Sonic beginning
his classic spin attack from the movies in the games
with the camera following his body as it spins,
then it switches to the black and red version of Sonic.
With the Red Lightning is meant to be shadow
the hedgehog, his sometimes evil clone.
Sometimes he helps them.
Their relationship is basically like another version
of Sonic and Knuckles from Sonic to
Knuckles started out by fighting against Sonic.
Then eventually they started working together against
Robotnik or Eggman, whoever you want to call him.
And it'll probably be the same arc for Shadow
the Hedgehog during Sonic three When Shadow learns
why he was created in the first place,
like what his true purpose was.
But the trailer depicts both of them using their spin
attacks against each other, just spinning
around the logo, charging up in the laugh you hear at
the end of the trailer is meant to be Jim Carrey.
Robotnik.
He's returned as Eggman.
There were a lot of people that thought that the laugh
could be coming from Hayden Christensen
because there's rumors
that he's doing the voice of Shadow in the movie,
and a lot of people would love to see Hayden
Christensen come back during this.
bell when they released the teaser trailer
the people behind the movie
released a bunch of articles confirming that Jim Carrey
had returned
from his brief retirement to play Robotnik again.
the only
reason people thought that he was done for good
was because he said he would retire
from acting after Sonic two.
But this was when Sonic two was coming out in theaters.
he said unless the greatest script in movie
history came to him.
So apparently Sonic three
is either going to be the best movie of all time,
like just the biggest banger,
or they offered him more money
than he's ever going to be able to spend,
typically it's the money reason.
the way they ended.
Sonic two,
they did leave a back door for him possibly returning
like I think they weren't quite sure
if Jim Carrey would want to return to the like.
We just need to give him an ending
that would allow them to explain
why he either does not come back
or why he does come back.
so at the end of Sonic to none of the authorities
or the military, the federal government ever found
his body, Robotnik had created this giant robot, split
the master Emerald into the seven chaos emeralds.
They use those to turn Sonic into his supersonic form.
Who destroys the robot?
But they never show you what happened to Robotnik
Spidey after the robot crashed to the ground
later, when the
government was combing the wreckage,
they just said they couldn't find his body.
And Agent Stone sort of sneaks
in wearing a uniform to reveal that he's still alive.
And he'll probably be the one to find and save Robotnik
so that he can return to try and finger
puppet control shadow to force him to fight Sonic
using all of his own abilities against him.
most of Shadow's
abilities are similar to Sonic's abilities,
which is why they're using the spin attack
against each other in the logo.
Pretty much
all the big characters are back from Sonic two.
They referenced Project Shadow
during that teaser at the end.
That's right out of the lore of the Sonic games,
In the teaser,
they say Project Shadow was a relic from 50 years ago.
So what they'll probably do is just explain it
like they do in the games.
It'll have it be Robotnik
grandfather who created Shadow just like they did in
Sonic Adventure to Generally, the plot of Sonic three
will be based on the plot of Sonic Adventure
two In the Lore of the Game's shadow
was created by Gerald Robotnik, the grandfather of Dr.
Robotnik Jim Carrey's character.
they'll probably use the movie to delve more into Robot
Nick's backstory with his family.
Like you can imagine Jim Carrey
getting Super Ham crazy on all this family relationship
that he didn't love me, Grandpa didn't love me
kind of stuff.
it'll make more sense when you understand
why his grandfather created Shadow
in the first place,
why he would been preoccupied with his experiments.
but the whole idea at the end of the movie
is the government found coordinates to shadow inside
Robot Nick's robot.
So he was already going to get shadow.
that's probably why you see
and come out of cryo storage at the end of the movie
like because he'd already activated his cryo tank.
they're not really clear why it took him
this long to go get Shadow out of storage.
You probably didn't think he needed Shadow
until the events of the second movie
because you only just met Sonic in the first movie,
then realized he would have needed Shadow.
Like, I'll go get that other spirit.
My grandfather created
but at the end of the first movie, he got stranded
on the other planet and just made it back
to planet Earth and then just got the master emerald.
So like, this is all happening
pretty quickly in the events of the movies.
so had he had a little more time, he probably would
have gotten shadow out of storage in the lore.
Shadow was a hybrid clone
created from the DNA from Sonic's
race and the black arms race who serve as antagonists.
Just in the general sense of the series.
But in present day of the games, most of the Black Arms
race has died off except for Black Doom,
who was their leader and spent all of his time trying
to conquer and enslave worlds, including the Earth.
So. Maybe.
Maybe we get some kind of teaser for Black Doom
at the end of this movie,
or at least some flashbacks to his race
to explain how shadow can exist
when they're sort of discovering Shadow
for the first time.
the whole reason why Robotnik grandfather
created Shadow and why Robotnik might hate
his grandfather or think that his grandfather
never cared about him was because he was trying
to solve the problem of immortality and cure
his granddaughter's fatal disease.
Maria Robotnik the whole idea is that shadow
wasn't created to be an evil being,
to conquer anyone
or even created to fight Sonic or Sonic's race.
it was all about saving his granddaughter, Maria.
I believe this actress is playing
Maria during the movie.
So it's just more of Robot Nick's family
they're introducing from the Lord.
it may be part of Robot.
Nick's arc in the movie
is eventually chilling a little bit once he realizes
why Shadow was created and what was really going on
with his cousin Maria, who is his cousin.
It's not his sister.
you can kind of see this from a Shadow's
perspective to where Shadow suddenly understands
why he was created in the first place.
Like, I'm not here to kill Sonic.
I'm actually here to help people.
and yes, a lot of people do think that Hayden
Christensen is voicing the shadow character.
That would be really cool after he came back as Darth
Vader and and Skywalker during Obi-Wan Kenobi in Asoka,
he did say that his desire to do more movies and TV
shows have been invigorated.
He got new agents, new management.
So this could just be a result of all that.
still, still really want to see him
do like a live action version of the Clone Wars series,
even though that would be the most expensive TV show
in the history of TV shows.
Krysten Ritter, who most people remember from
the Marvel Netflix Defenders series from Jessica Jones.
She's actually coming back
during that, too, in the new MCU stuff.
She's in the movie in.
Most people believe she's playing a version of Rouge
the Bad,
just because of all the new characters
that they announced that they're doing in the movie.
She seems the most similar
to the kind of character that Krysten Ritter
would actually be playing In the lore.
She was meant to be a jewel thief, as in chaos
emeralds, the master emerald working
for the federal government on earth.
But sometimes she's good, sometimes she's bad.
She has a weakness for jewels.
So you can see how she just likes stealing stuff.
Generally,
she's meant to be one of Sonic's allies. Cool.
Easter egg for the games too.
When they were making Sonic Adventure two, which is
basically informing the plot of the Sonic three movie.
Originally,
the developers of the game called Her Shadow
and originally they developed the shadow character
for Sonic Adventure two.
But when they were developing the game, they called him
Terry O's, but then they switched the names
and they started calling the actual shadow
character Shadow instead of calling her rouge the bad.
maybe they'll be a couple of jokes about that
at some point during the movie.
eventually, during the game,
she helps Sonic defeat Black Doom.
But I'm not expecting Black Doom
to be like a real main villain of Sonic three.
I still think that Robotnik is meant
to be one of the main villains for most of the film.
would they might do after they resolve
all the conflicts during the movies,
they might tease black doom for like a future film.
If they do a fourth movie For the most part, though,
all the big characters from Sonic
two are back like Tails Knuckles.
There is that Knuckles TV show that they're making
with Idris Elba's version from the movies.
We don't have a trailer for that yet,
but we'll probably see more characters from the movies
also show up during that.
Those are probably used to introduce more characters
from the games to if there's any other Easter eggs
or references that you spotted in any of the teasers
they dropped for Sonic three,
just write them below in the comments and I'll do more
trailer videos as they release them later this year.
The movie's not coming out till the end of the year,
so it's going to be a while
before we get the next big trailer.
like I said, next week is the American Super Bowl.
If you live outside the United States, it's
basically like a trailer fest.
everybody drops their really big trailers.
The biggest one is supposed to be the Deadpool
three trailer, expecting that to break the Internet.
Of course,
I will do videos for as many of them as possible,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel.
So you don't miss any of that.
Speaking of Krysten Ritter, big connection
to what's happening with Daredevil born again
in the Marvel Universe right now.
Like all the Marvel Netflix defenders
characters are coming back through Daredevil Born Again
eventually, including Krysten Ritter
as her version of Jessica Jones.
Click here for that first teaser trailer
for all that stuff and click here for all my Deadpool
3 teaser trailers.
There been a couple of them recently.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!